[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
63 it is january 16th that i get it
right
it's january 16th and we are ready to
talk about
the amazing events of the present and
what might be
in store for us in the near future so
how does that sound all right let's do
it that sounds good
all right good uh let me just see are
there any things that we need to cover
up front
other than the general cat madness that
is surrounding us and uh if we are
attacked please call 9-1-1 on our behalf
yeah um just the usual we have
apparently there's already a lot of
super chat uh
questions coming in uh we appreciate
those we try to answer as many as
possible
in the second hour which will not be uh
hearable for those of you who will be
listening in later as a podcast
uh but for those of you tuning in on
youtube you
can see that in the second video uh from
the same
uh from the same day and great and if
you are
listening on the podcast version check
out the youtube version you might like
the q a it's pretty exciting we look
forward to it
and uh anyway so there's a lot more
material there
so should we give people a sense of
where we're going yeah let's do that so
you're gonna you're gonna start
and um you're gonna you're gonna start
with some
political suggestions i would say
apolitical suggestions but yeah that's
the general area a political suggestions
yes apolitical uh a not singular
because suggestions of course is plural
but uh like above politics
i see uh non-ideological a political
suggestions for how we might a political
suggestion right
got it okay yes okay well you thought it
was like an harmonica or something no
it's
it's a political suggestions fair enough
all right
um so uh you're gonna start there then
we're gonna talk a little bit about
a um a paper that just came out uh
suggesting some kind of dire news about
covet and we're going to
look into that paper and uh figure out
what it means and
and what it suggests about what we
should be doing and
uh talk a little bit a little bit maybe
about uh
some vaccine deployment in some other
parts of the world
and um maybe spend some time talking
about eagles
yeah i think we should uh we should do
that actually i think it actually fits
perfectly as a sort of bookend
for the other the other part of the
apology being a political yes
yes yeah eagles being fiercely
apolitical
i mean ferociously almost aggressively
aggressively and blood thirstily
apolitical i would say
certainly the the rodents that they hunt
would feel that way
yes full of blood rodents are all right
um
well i think we can avoid it no longer
uh
here is what i want to talk about and i
i do this with um i think a certain
amount of trepidation but i don't think
there's uh really anything else
to be to be done so i've been like
everyone else wrestling with the
question of where we find ourselves in
the aftermath
of what i think was clearly um an
insurrection on the part of most of the
people
that is the self-diagnosis i would say
or consistent with the self-diagnosis of
many of the people
who stormed the capital for those who
want to know more about what it looked
like on the ground i would
advise people check in with the
interview i did with jeremy
lee quinn who was a journalist who was
not only on the ground at the capitol
but went into the capital and reported
firsthand he's got fascinating stuff on
his website and you can get a real sense
for what it felt like on the ground
which is something that is missing from
most of the
um the mainstream coverage um but
what i see in the aftermath of that
event
is a lot of people making political
moves that is to say i see uh a lot of
advocacy for various positions some of
the positions i think
are in the interests of the nation but i
see
most of the motivation that appears to
be driving people even to suggest things
that i would agree with
appears to be about jockeying for
position in a very traditional way and i
don't think that's appropriate given
where we find ourselves here at the
beginning of 2021 so i wanted to take a
little bit
of time to speak to what i think is
um the patriotic center i've said many
times i'm not a centrist
but the center is where we meet to
discover the or to discuss the interests
of the nation and to figure out
where to go and this if there was ever a
time when we need to meet in the center
and discuss what is in our collective
interests it's now
um so what i see is that we are faced
with
um various exotic remedies to a
situation
i would say the three exotic remedies uh
that seem to be present
are the 25th amendment impeachment which
has already happened
and pardons those are the exotic
remedies
and then there's a question about how
they might be wielded
and to what end and of course each of
them
carries various implications for the
future and what i would
suggest in fact what i think we should
demand from our leaders
is that they step outside of their
tribalistic
team allegiances and start thinking
about what the implications of their
actions are going to be
now i would say i would certainly
ask that people in listening to my
suggestion
my proposal here that people put
judgment aside because we have each been
trained
to look for evidence that somebody is on
the opposing side and as soon as we get
that evidence we
jump now my feeling is what needs to be
done here
is not going to make anyone perfectly
happy but that
the most important thing on the table
is protected if we
act courageously and carefully so my
proposal would be
starting with the impeachment which has
already happened that the house
impeached the president i want to see
the senate come back into session
and convict the president i believe that
is not only
justified by the merits of the case but
it is also
very definitely in the nation's interest
it is in the nation's interest in the
sense that if president trump
is not convicted he remains eligible to
run in 2024 and i believe what we will
see
is a effectively a four-year
campaign for trump to return to office
now
no matter what you think about donald
trump i would say
it is absolutely clear that he
is not the person to unite the nation
he did have special skills that allowed
him to beat the republican party and
ascend to the highest office in the land
but he did not have
the skills to make use of that office
to bring us into some new era and that's
uh tragic but i think it is very clear
and
that the insurrection at the end of his
uh his term is evidence of that
so to the extent that we may need
somebody to escape
the duopoly's grasp it isn't going to be
donald trump and it won't be donald
trump
in 2024 and
the idea that we are going to live under
the shadow of that possibility for the
next four years
should frighten all of us now i see
republicans playing with the idea
of convicting trump but at some level
it's hard to avoid the impression
that the senate republicans are simply
weighing
the hazard to them politically of
of convicting trump against the
possibility that many consider desirable
of being free of his influence
over the next four years so i would like
to see them
convict him but i would also like to see
them do it as a matter of partnership
and frankly this is what i see
missing from the larger discussion is a
partnership between
the various players in in this in other
words i would like to have seen the
house
collaborate with the senate i would like
to have seen democrats
collaborate with republicans i would
like to see the senate now
um in partnership with vice president
pence
agree that donald trump must be
convicted
in order that he cannot run in 2024 and
because what he did do
was encourage although indirectly the
assault
on the capital but that pence when he
assumes
the office of president should pardon
president
trump right thereby alleviating the
potential
for federal prosecution um
that i believe is the
uh the route that is best for the nation
i would also
argue that pres that he would then be
president pence
uh should pardon all of the
insurrectionists who did not engage
in direct violence against other human
beings
as well as the blm protesters who did
not involve themselves in direct
violence against other human beings
now this may all seem very radical and
strange but there is clear precedent for
this
um zach could you put up the um
the uh it's the federalist paper the
hamilton
federalist paper that i sent you now i
may not be able to read this
one of ours yeah if you can put it up so
i can read it that would be great
i can read it
yeah that's some fine print there
larger and last paragraph
okay so i should say i was pointed to
this by
a friend of ours ramsay rammerman who is
a lawyer um and quite well schooled in
this
um he points me to this last paragraph
of what is federalist 74 is that right
zach
say that at the top scroll back up
federalist 74 from 1788
and so hamilton says uh on the other
hand
when the sedition had proceeded from
causes which had inflamed the
resentments of the major party they
might often be found
obstinate and inexorable when policy
demanded a conduct of forbearance and
clemency
but the principal argument for reposing
the power of pardoning in this case to
the chief magistrate
is this in seasons of insurrection or
rebellion
there are often critical moments when a
well-timed offer of pardon to the
insurgents or rebels
may restore the tranquility of the
commonwealth and which
if suffered to pass if suffered to pass
unimproved it may never be possible
afterwards to
recall what he is saying here
so this the entirety of this he writes
as uh
pub uh publius here which is a shared
gnome de plume of several founders
what he is saying here the purpose of
this federalist paper
is an argument for vesting the power of
the pardon
in the single chief executive now
in part so i'm going back through
history i don't know terribly well but
in part shay's rebellion which
bears some striking resemblance to
certain things that have taken place at
place actually on both sides of the
political spectrum in the last year
shea's rebellion was a
an insurrection that was
the result of essentially
soldiers most especially shays who
found themselves in a debt crisis not
being
and not having been paid for their
military service
and the result of that insurrection
which was put down by
a private army there was no federal army
the result of that insurrection was to
reveal to many of the founders the need
for a strong central authority
and hamilton here is arguing in part in
response to
shea's rebellion that the power of the
pardon
is best vested in an individual rather
than a committee
and his point effectively is uh it's
actually parallel to one that you and i
have made on the podcast in various
places about
things like parenting which is that a
system in order to work well
in light of a vast array of
possibilities that can't be foreseen
when you build it
has to have discretion right parents
cannot just simply lay down rules that
result in children
growing up well you have to have
discretion about when you know
to inflict harsh punishment when to uh
to
resist that urge and so hamilton is
making the argument that the interests
of the nation
involve a single individual who is
poised at a particularly critical moment
like the one that we face right now to
deploy the pardon to relieve the
pressure that might otherwise tear us
apart and his point is
if you let that moment go you may never
get it back that's what he's saying in
that
in that paragraph this certainly seems
like such a moment
and uh the the tensions on both sides
are incredibly high and and
people who have not been engaging in the
riots and
violence on either side whatever tribe
to which they think they belong
are fairly eager to keep their anger
alive
and demand vengeance and this would be a
way
of preventing such vengeance and of
intentionally and permanently putting it
in the rearview mirror putting the
possibility of such vengeance in the
rear-view mirror
yes taking many things off the table now
it is complicated by the fact that it at
a pardon of any of these folks only
would immunize them from federal
prosecution but it could be done
in such a way that it would invite the
states to follow suit
and i would advocate for that and in
effect this
does mean that people who have clearly
committed criminal acts
would in effect get away with it but
what i would suggest is that this be
done
in tandem with a
a an agreement that the rule of law
must stand it must be enforced it cannot
be enforced differentially
and therefore it should come
with a no tolerance policy
for violence rioting insurrection
going forward right that is to say we
relieve the pressure
with amnesty and i should say shays
himself was pardoned
there were a uh it's not as clear as
everyone involved in his rebellion which
was i think 4
000 people they were not all pardoned
but
in general all but a few received
clemency of one kind
or another so again this is precedented
and were we to find ourselves in a
situation
where president pence had partnered with
the congress we had
eliminated the threat of living under a
four-year campaign
of trump potentially returning to office
trump and his supporters would also
effectively be protected from
the spectacle of federal prosecutions of
trump going forward which are
likely to occur under democratic rule so
um all of these things would serve to
relieve the pressure
i have the sense you had something you
wanted to add there i mean
there are a number of things to say i
guess one one concern obviously
is that this would i believe do as you
suggest and would relieve the pressure
at the governmental and
legal level but as we talked about last
week
a lot of what we're seeing is extra
governmental action
by private corporations who are
effectively acting
uh as you know in the public good in
their own eyes
in censoring for instance the trump as
the trump
the president and and others who uh who
the tech companies imagine are dangerous
to discourse
and civilization i agree and obviously
there's a lot to be discussed
there and we should come back to it uh
it will probably take weeks of looking
at different
aspects of the puzzle but there is an
awful lot to be said there but i would
say to the extent that what we have
is a ferocious powerful and new weapon
in the hands of
a strangely aligned
industry that has a very clear political
bent the last thing
that we want to see is that apparatus
liberated to behave in an authoritarian
way
by the fact of trump attempting to
regain the office in
2024 and frankly i think almost as
frightening
as the prospect of the four years under
that
is the prospect of the trials unfolding
in public view
so to the extent that we can relieve
this pressure we also relieve the
justification that the tech sector will
use in order to crack down on voices it
doesn't like
i guess i'm not sure i'm not sure about
your use of the term liberating i don't
think
uh the the tech companies need any
liberation to do what they want clearly
you know they feel they already feel
plenty free
to act as as they desire um what i do
think this could do which could um
very much help change the conversation
and alleviate some of the
some of the ramping up that is happening
is
by taking trump out of the equation
you immediately remove and put again in
the rear view mirror
the single source of anger and ire that
um you know call it half call it half of
america has and i don't think it's
actually fully half but
you know half of america has for um
for someone and they have pinned so many
people have pinned
um and it's the opposite of hopes like
all of their dismay
and their imagine you know the source of
everything wrong in the world
on this guy and that's not fair right
um you know he's he's definitely
culpable for a lot of stuff but that's
not fair
and um and yet you know i
i was i was literally walking around
downtown portland
uh this this week and overheard two
different conversations between
two different sets of it turns out to
have been young women
i'm assuming they're gender um in in
in all these cases um but you know for a
total of four
four women who were just gleeful
in their you know in their rage and they
imagined
um deserved rage at the second
impeachment which had just happened
um i think just just then is at the
point that i was walking around
and i thought what happens you know what
happens to their conversations and what
happens to their personalities and what
happens to their
um imaginations and plans for the future
at the point that the single enemy in
their world goes away
we can hope that some number of these
people actually
uh return to a semblance of thinking
more clearly
more broadly about a range of issues now
i don't think
you're listening to your conversation
with jeremy lee quinn you're your second
one the the almost three-hour one
um that was just posted last week um you
know he says
um they're there are plenty of people
uh he doesn't say there are plenty of
people he says there are those
who are arguing really for anarchy and
for destruction at any cost it doesn't
matter from whom or
for what it doesn't matter so those
people will not be appeased
and and those people are very dangerous
and they've been very active on the
so-called left since the beginning of
the summer
and he was suggesting somewhat present
also in the insurrection on the capitol
last week
uh two weeks ago week and a half ago so
you know those people won't
be helped by this but there are a whole
lot of people who are
just so focused on the one enemy that if
you take
away that enemy maybe they could recover
well yes i think this is uh this is
central
which is that these fringes are driving
the conversation
and so two things have to be true you
know i hope it was clear in what i said
at the top that um amnesty for what has
happened
in the past coming with a an insistence
on the rule of law going forward
is key and i would point out rule of law
is the apolitical way of saying this
that trump has
politicized the question by saying law
and order all the time
which is typically a right-wing thing
but
rule of law is something we all ought to
be able to agree on it is essential to
the functioning of our society
actually someone um i think i saw in our
q a last week a question we hadn't
gotten to a suggestion that
uh rule of law and law and order were
wrestle conjugations of one another
so this is basically what you've what
you've just said i believe they are yeah
i don't know if they were i mentioned
this on the trigonometry podcast
just right after the the insurrection
had happened but
um so i want to make a couple last
points one of them quite
uh concordant with what you just said um
so the fringes are indeed driving the
conversation
for others and it occurred to me
actually it occurred to me listening to
eric
on the hill program
rising a couple days ago maybe it was
yesterday even
he mentions what he calls magistan
and wokistan and these are the two
fringes in question and it occurred to
me
that something i have been saying
since the beginning since before trump
was elected
that the problem with this slogan maga
is that it is intentionally
polarizing and it's the second a in mega
that does it
the idea that america should be made
great again
suggests all sorts of things it suggests
that it has been great now i think it is
a country with a tremendous amount of
greatness to it but i don't think it has
ever been great for everybody
i don't think it's ever been great for
blacks i don't think it's ever been
great for indians and
until it's great for everybody it isn't
great it's a prototype of great so
by saying again it sort of suggests that
we had it and somebody screwed it up and
now we're looking for villains
but what occurred to me in hearing eric
invoke
magistan and wikistan was that
it is the exact desire
to misunderstand the past all the way to
turn your misunderstanding to 11
in one of two directions that creates
these um
yin-yang fringes right so the mega folks
are trying to get us back to somewhere
that we never were right
and the wokistan folks are
essentially arguing that this country is
bad at its core that that's what it was
founded to do
that there is no possibility of making
it great therefore
tearing it down is the only reasonable
action
and the point is both of these things
are equally crazy
right the country was never great in the
sense of great for all populations it
certainly has marched a long way in that
direction we have made tremendous
progress but we're not there
and it is reasonable to demand that we
get there it is not reasonable
to want to go back and it is not
reasonable to tear it down on the basis
that it's such an evil place
um that we will almost inevitably do
better if we try again that's
utter nonsense so recognizing the
insanity of these two positions
and therefore the necessity to alleviate
their control over the discussion
how do we alleviate their control by
sidelining them
at this moment and saying okay what's
happened has happened
what must happen going forward is the
law must be
enforced irrespective of who it is who's
breaking it
and you know that period of relief makes
a great deal of sense
i guess um i'm just i'm surprised i'm
this guy at this point but um
i'm concerned that alleviating
uh the the pressure taking away
some of the remaining power in so far as
it exists excuse me
from the mega people leaves
much of the power that is like i said
extra governmental and of course there's
plenty of governmental power as well
um among the the welcome standards uh if
you will
that um that not just the tech
the tech companies but obviously media
and and much else and you know in
corporate america are at least
um virtue signaling you know putting up
their you know whether it's don't hurt
me walls
or they actually have people in their um
in their hr departments who believe this
stuff
or anything in between from academia to
um to corporations to media
um the the the majority of what we are
expected to believe
is very much slanted towards woken
rather than magistan
and you know we're arguing we shouldn't
have either but
um you know how how is it that we
actually disempower
both of those things well i think this
is a great
point and i think um it ought to be our
focus but
in part i think we also need to
understand that we don't exactly know
why we are where we are in other words
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
that has
you know the tech sector which is
ostensibly a bunch of corporations in
competition with each other
behaving as if they are one monster yeah
we don't know exactly what the
interaction is between
that entity and our governmental
structures for one thing
we've in part lost control of our
governmental structures there's the part
we can see and there's the part we can't
and actually this brings me
to what i would say is the last piece of
the puzzle that i would hope to see
deployed in the next few days before
before the uh the inauguration which is
i would hope to see the pardon of
snowden and assange
now snowden i would say is a national
hero
for what he did for bringing
transparency where
there was authoritarianism and
opacity it's harder to say that about
assange because he's not an american but
nonetheless i would hope to see those
pardons and frankly you know if
if i had all of the cards to play of all
the various players i would probably
have trump pardon them
before he is convicted by the senate as
an
indication that actually you know he uh
he is willing to do his part for the
well-being of the nation
even even in his uh wounded condition so
um anyway i don't know what will come of
this i frankly expect nothing will come
of it because these actors are so
political they're
died in the wool partisans and so
the idea that they would ever do
anything that wasn't justified by
its immediately elevating them relative
to their competitors is almost hard to
imagine
at some level partisanship is the
opposite of patriotism it is
that's very well said it is the opposite
of patriotism patriotism is about
putting your interest
aside in the interest of something
larger a nation for example
um and so it's a rare commodity these
days but
who knows maybe they will surprise us in
a positive direction
if nothing else they should look at the
prospect of a future
lived under the cloud of either a
four-year campaign
by trump to regain the office or a
long series of highly publicized and
charged trials
of uh president trump neither of those
things are going to leave us better off
as a nation and anybody who says
otherwise
is uh is a liar frankly yeah
all right all right i think i think
we've reached it okay
um next section then oh
and my computer chooses this moment to
fail
um so a new paper came out this week
uh finding that asymptomatic cases of
covid account for possibly half of all
new infections
uh let's just um so if you're a
uh long-standing listener of this
podcast you will recognize that is a
shocking conclusion for a paper yeah
zach can you put my screen on for a
moment so here it is it's an
um jama network open i i found it
through
um i'm in the i guess it's the weekly
jama jama is the journal of the american
medical association
newsletter um and they had this
uh they they had this in the newsletter
and it's got over 200 000 views at this
point which is a crazy high number for
a scientific paper but we were talking
about over dinner last night we don't
know what views means here so i
guarantee you 200 000 people haven't
studied this paper and the kind of topic
that i have for instance
no but in light of the fact that it's
jamma
right journal of the american medical
association carries a lot of weight
it's a high clout location and that they
are broadcasting on their website even
if that's just people who have clicked
through
and seen this conclusion deployed under
that banner
that is an amazingly powerful fact yeah
and so here
let me actually just before i say
something about what the paper finds um
the the sections of a scientific paper
are generally
abstract introduction methods or methods
of materials
results discussion and then references
cited so the abstract is the summary the
author's summary of what it is that the
paper finds
the introduction sets up the uh the
extent research the background research
and the theoretical framing for the work
that they're doing the methods or
methods of materials whatever
describes exactly what it is that they
did
hopefully with enough detail such that
someone else could go in with the
methods and
redo their work and thus effectively
replicate that work
the results is um just supposed to be
a description of what they found the
analysis you know having then done what
they described that they were going to
do in the methods
they did that off-site and then they
describe the results including the
analysis the statistical analysis of the
results the results is not supposed to
include
any interpretation and then the
discussion is exactly the interpretation
you sort of come full circle
and you say you know given what we
thought we knew given what our
hypothesis was hopefully
um you know what is it that we found and
what do we make of it in light of the
other things that we know to be true and
then the reference to site is just that
all the references that
uh were cited um to uh you know
in a paper like this um to make the
sorts of decisions for how it was that
they were assessing
background numbers so in this case the
abstract
is a fairly detailed so here you can
show my screen again zach
is is actually split up into several
sections and in the results section
they have no no in conclusions and
relevance rather
in this decision analytical sorry in
this decision analytical model
of multiple scenarios for proportions of
asymptomatic individuals with covet 19
and infectious periods
transmission from asymptomatic
individuals was estimated to account for
more than half of all transmissions
in addition to identification and
isolation of persons with symptomatic
covet 19
effective control of spread will require
reducing the risk of transmission from
people with infection
who do not have symptoms these findings
suggest that measures such as wearing
masks
hand hygiene social distancing and
strategic testing of people who are not
ill
will be foundational to slowing the
spread of coven 19 until safe and
effective vaccines are available and
widely used
so let me say just with regard to that
last sentence that regardless of what
else might be true about this paper
um we have been since our very first
live stream in late march at the point
that
the who and the surgeon general had um
you know were recently arguing that mask
squaring was not useful
at all um you know advocating for mask
wearing and
hygiene and you know social distancing
and all of these things right
but this paper effectively claims
to have finally done the work that a lot
of people have been looking for
and and has found this really alarming
result
that over half of the cases
are are actually spread due to
asymptomatic individuals and they
and they they're careful here they
specify that there are three classes
there are symptomatic individuals of
people who have tested positive they're
symptomatic individuals
there are pre-symptomatic individuals
and there are what they're calling never
symptomatic individuals and they're
trying to tease apart the
pre-symptomatic from the never
symptomatic the idea being the
pre-symptomatic
there's really low reason to expect that
they will be much
less transmitting of disease although
perhaps somewhat
so this is really bad news right this is
so
it you said it's alarming but i also
want to separate that from surprising
um so again people who've watched us
will know this piece of logic but
what piece of logic the the idea that it
would be surprising to have
a very high rate of totally asymptomatic
transmission and the reason
is that the very things that allow a
virus to be transmitted
are the things that cause symptoms that
is to say if you imagine for example
uh cells in your lung that have been
invaded by a virus that are now spilling
forth virus to invade
other cells and to escape into the
environment
then that's a piece of damage in your
lung that will cause irritation
will cause mucus etc so the idea is in
typically speaking you would expect
symptoms
to be correlated with the degree of
illness and therefore the degree of
infectivity so this is not only
a shocking result at the level of oh my
goodness
this is a very dangerous phenomenon if
that's true but it's surprising at a
scientific level
yeah it is um luckily for us the paper
is complete garbage
i mean it's really actually stunning how
much complete garbage is in this paper
so um i could spend several hours going
through the garbage nature of the paper
and i'm not going to bore everyone with
that
it is going to be a little bit a little
bit numbery here
um so you're going to condense
down the garbage in this paper making
you a trash compactor
yeah that's right that's what i am for
today a trash compactor
my god um and so
my intention here was not to dunk on
this paper i clicked on this link
um in the jama newsletter the title
you know the title again is uh sars cov2
transmission from people without covet
19 symptoms
and uh and
it looks really alarming and the fact is
i read this
i read this actually as i was making
dinner last night which sounds like a
strange thing to do but it was possible
given
the dinner i was making and then i read
the references that they had used to
support their their assumptions
and i came to dinner kind of alarmed and
then i read it again and then i read it
again this morning and um it just
frankly it gets
it gets more shoddy more clearly shoddy
the more times
you look at it so i'll hold on i gotta
jump in again um
so i also want to point out how unusual
that behavior is
which behavior the behavior you just
described for yourself with respect
to this paper and i just want to say
that for various reasons some of them
totally mundane
very frequently people end up repeating
they will read an abstract of a paper
maybe they scan what's in the rest and
they will report based on that as if
it's true rather than saying
wow i mean in fact one of my advisors
charles handley
um used to joke uh i think maybe it was
widely said in his era
may all your abstracts come true right
the idea being that you know an abstract
is not an indication that the work is
necessarily
well i mean we're this is not at all
what we're supposed to be talking about
here but um
i suspect i was not there to hear
charles say that yeah i don't think i
ever even met him but
my suspicion is that that was about you
having to write an abstract before
for preventing your talk at a conference
so you have to write what you think
you're going to find before you even
done the research for a talk that's
going to be given nine months in the
future
that's true in fairness he was he was
referring to that in the particular case
i will say though that the number of
times that what is in the abstract is
not justified by what is in the paper is
alarmingly high
and therefore one has to you know it's
one
thing if you're looking at somebody
whose work you know very well
and you know that it's careful and then
their latest paper comes out and you
look at the abstract and you say
this person found that right but it's
another thing
to just take some piece of work you know
nothing about
and assume that what's in the abstract
is justified by what's in the paper
it's very commonly not and yet as soon
as something especially something
sensational emerges
in the form of a title and an abstract
it will be cited and repeated
and there's no way of knowing almost no
one is going to actually have read the
paper much less a few times
much multiple times excuse me much less
um
have gone through and figured out the
and read the sources that they are
citing which is
which is the part where i said okay i
you know they're just
they're just not doing good work here so
let's go through it as
briefly as pop possible so this paper is
a model
that's then based on um some combination
of empirical research and review papers
and models themselves so what what are
these terms again since we've already
defined sort of what the parts of a
research paper are
a model is trying to generate
a predictive basically equation or set
of equations
that will reveal something that is true
about the universe having fed in
some actual data and then hopefully the
model has
enough general predictive value um that
you could take it to a different system
um either you know a different place or
at a different time or maybe even a
slightly different
you know in this case disease possibly
and say okay what
um you know what would you have to tweak
to have this model continue to be true
um so this this paper is just describing
a model and results from a model there's
nothing empirical here
empirical meaning they went out and they
actually
took data they actually measured data
themselves measured
made measurements themselves and brought
that data back into the analysis
and then there are also review papers
which go into the literature and say
okay i've got
you know i found eight papers that are
relevant to the thing that i'm trying to
figure out let me do a meta analysis
on those and see what if i take them in
the aggregate they might find
so this is a model that's based on some
combination of empirical research and
review papers and aggregates
so it is a model they have developed
from empirical work
somewhat from empirical work not
entirely from empirical work but so
that's you know fair enough
let's that's done broadly we have
critiqued models and modeling systems in
the past and we will continue to do so
but
models aren't inherently flawed right
you just have to understand that it's
not the same as empirical research
in the results of the abstract so again
the results section and this is not the
results section of the paper but the
results of the abstract
the result section is supposed to
supposed to include only what it is that
they found
they say quote the baseline assumptions
for the model
were that peak infectiousness occurred
at the medium
let me start again the baseline
assumptions for the model were that peak
infectiousness occurred at the median of
symptom onset
and that 30 of individuals with
infection never develop symptoms
and are 75 as infectious as those who do
develop symptoms
so they have just told us in the results
section now less of the abstract
that they used assumptions
of 75 infectiousness of asymptomatic
individuals
in building this model which then popped
out the result that asymptomatic
individuals
are responsible for up to 50 of cases
this is a problem this is a big problem
so on what basis
did they put that assumption of 75
infectiousness of asymptomatic
individuals
into this model which pretends which
proclaims to actually
find a symptomatic transmission
when what we've just been told in the
actual results of the abstract
is that that was an assumption of the
model so
in the method section the actual method
section of the paper they clarified this
way quote
we also made a baseline assumption that
individuals with asymptomatic infections
are an average 75 percent as infectious
as those with symptomatic infections oh
wait that's not clarifying that's just a
repeat of what they already said except
at least it's in the proper part of the
paper now they're acknowledging that
this is the methods this is something
that they actually fed into their model
they then cite for this claim how is it
that they generated this number 75
percent of
um uh asymptomatic individuals are 75
as infectious as symptomatic individuals
this is again not a finding of this
paper this is an assumption they use to
build the model
they cite references 9 5 and 15 and 16
to support this
so i went and read references 9 15 and
16.
i'll return there but uh
in the meantime before we get there
recognize that
everything downstream of this assumption
absolutely everything downstream of this
assumption they use to build their model
this assumption that asymptomatic
individuals are 75
as infectious as not as symptomatic
individuals
cannot reveal anything
about whether or not individuals are
actually infectious because they've
built that into the model everything
downstream is suspect
they've built the assumption into their
model in fact they can't find anything
else because they've built it in it's
circular there is no way for them to
come to a different conclusion
absolutely no way
okay so their results um r
holding the day of um
yeah actually here i'm gonna show this
figure in a minute when i find it zach
okay here we go
zach if you can show my screen so this
is figure one this
is you know it seems super mathy and
very confusing
oh it looks very sciencey yes um so
figure one the contribution of
asymptomatic transmission under
different infection profiles
we are gonna for the moment actually for
the entire duration of this
this podcast skip down to the second row
d e and f about which they say panels d
e and f show different proportions of
transmissions from individuals who are
never symptomatic
um in in uh let's see
in d we have baseline 75
relative infectivity um and
e 75 relative infectivity and in this
one they did change the relative
infectivity so they have changed the
baseline assumption here to
100 relative infectivity they went right
up to like
asymptomatic individuals we're just
going to assume that asymptomatic
individuals
are exactly as infectious as symptomatic
individuals and we are going to be
shocked totally shocked when our model
produces
a result that says that asymptomatic
individuals
are close to us infectious and as
symptomatic individuals how does this
pass for science i just don't i i
cannot i cannot believe that this got
through
anything like these scientists brains or
peer review or anything so
okay zach and i have thank you um
how did they arrive at this number the
75 baseline assumption and then
on what basis are they claiming to have
messed with their assumptions but
actually only ever
changed it in the upward direction they
only ever decided to look at
75 as infectious as symptomatic cases
for asymptomatic or a hundred percent
those are the only two numbers that they
actually looked at
well um the authors themselves
say show in okay once more zack if you
would in the method section
this table key assumptions and evidence
in forming those assumptions
and here we're going to look at this
section right here
relative infectiousness of individuals
who never have symptoms
and here we have these three references
again
lee at all which is reference nine they
say they looked at 303 patients
and found approximately 100 as
infectious wow okay
okay that male then 75 seems like a
decent estimate okay
cha at all 2020 which was their
reference 15.
they uh this paper says they looked at
1701
uh secondary contacts and found an
infection rate of asymptomatic compared
to symptomatic individuals of 40 to 140
percent
wow okay that's asymptomatic individuals
are
more infectious than symptomatic
individuals according to this paper
better go look at the paper
curiouser and curious curiouser and
curiouser yes and then the third
reference that this
johansson at all paper looks at is
mcavoy at all
um which is actually a a modeling paper
itself
actually it's a review paper that tries
to do some modeling and they found
a mere 40 to 70 percent and and from
those three numbers
these authors concluded 75 percent about
right
so well let's see if any of those
numbers hold
right let's let's see what we have in
um there we go
um nope hold on zach thank you um
in li at all uh what they did was they
looked at 303 actual patients in a
health center in south korea
uh cool it's it's empirical
this paper finds compellingly that viral
load
and asymptomatic patients is similar to
that in symptomatic patients
okay and they're not the on this is not
the only paper actually to have to have
found that that viral load is similar in
asymptomatic patients
and symptomatic patients but guess what
viral load
is not the same thing as infectiousness
or transmissibility
it's just not it's not the same thing
and
the authors of this paper leonol which
are cited by johansson at all to support
their ridiculous claim that a hundred
percent
they so this leodoll paper johansson is
claiming
claims a hundred percent as infectious
for asymptomatic versus symptomatic
patients
say quote although the high viral load
we observed in asymptomatic patients
raises a distinct possibility of a risk
for transmission our study was not
designed to determine this
and under the limitations of their own
work they say quote
we did not determine the role that
molecular viral shedding played in
transmission from asymmetric patients
so take away one of those three
references that johansson had all fined
doesn't provide any evidence of
transmissibility much less 100
okay that's one we are going to get
through these other two pretty quickly
reference 15
cha at all uh it's an empirical paper
tracking cases in brunei we're following
a super spreader event in malaysia so
brunei is a small country
there was a a a big event like 16 000
people a religious event in malaysia
some number of people came home to
brunei and and a small country
uh with a lot of track and trace
possible and said they were actually
able to
to look at um what happened so another
empirical paper
that's pretty well done actually i was i
was um pretty impressed with this
it's a complicated analysis with a lot
of variables and
um just a reminder that uh
johannes and it all find um
that this paper found forty to a hundred
and forty percent
of cases uh uh for forty two hundred
forty percent
of asymptomatic case no asymptomatic
cases are
40 to 140 as infectious as symptomatic
cases
that's what johansson reports about this
paper well what does this paper actually
find
it finds that um in the household
setting
which is the only settings where they
could find anything statistically
significant
symptomatic case patients had 2.7 times
the risk of transmitting cysco v2
as combined asymptomatic and
pre-symptomatic patients
so that's a conservative member so you
know again sorry for all the numbers
but almost three times as much
infectiousness in symptomatic patients
versus the combined asymptomatic and
pre-symptomatic and never symptomatic
patients
and when you look further into their
paper you find that of course the
pre-symptomatic
patients are more infectious than the
never symptomatic patients
and what you don't find is any evidence
for 40 to 140 percent
there's nothing in this paper at all
that suggests
that asymptomatic patients are more
infectious than symptomatic patients so
where are they getting these numbers
quickly just the last paper is a review
paper
uh and they they're doing it carefully
it's review through only through april
8th 2020 so it's you know early in the
pandemic
which separates out never symptomatic
from pre-symptomatic cases
and um it's a careful review and what
they do is they say
we can't tell there's not enough out
there yet the literature is not rich
enough
there's not enough empirical work we
simply can't tell and they specifically
point to variable definitions of what
infectiousness means
and they say okay so very tentatively
given that
we think that maybe asymptomatics have
about a 0.4 to 0.7 rate of
infectiousness to that of symptomatics
which is exactly the number that that
johansson
cite here and if you could just show my
screen one more time zach once again we
have these three papers that the new
johansson is basing their the neutral
handsome papers basing their numbers on
leodoll which was from south korea which
actually
has in my finding no evidence at all
for transfer transmissibility and
johansson says approximately 100 percent
cha at all which was the case from
brunei which
as far as i can tell shows a third or
less
asymptomatic patients are a third or
less infectious
as symptomatic patients and they say 40
to 140 percent
on the basis of which i i cannot even
begin to figure out
and mcavoy at all uh which is a highly
tentative number says 40 to 70
well that number they actually got right
you can see that here they actually got
that number
they pulled it directly from the paper
and it's you know it's right there
so my conclusion from all of this
is that johansson had all this new paper
which i expect to start seeing reflected
in um you know in the cdc's guidelines
and various health officials
recommended behavioral changes um
is that their their baseline assumption
of 75
infectiousness of asymptomatic relative
to symptomatic cases is
completely unfounded completely
unfounded and
it's possible but we literally have
no evidence for that in the papers that
they cite
given that nothing in the conclusions of
this paper should be taken seriously
no policy should be based on it and we
should
seriously question any of the work that
these guys are doing going forward
because what the hell were they thinking
so can you go back to the title of the
uh the piece the
the main one yeah yeah sars covi2
transmission from people without covid19
symptoms so i think
a i'm wondering whether our longtime
uh viewers are having a bit of deja vu
because if you allow yourself to squint
at this just right
it is very much like the situation and
unfortunately i didn't realize until we
were on the air
what the parallel was so i don't have
the name of the paper but
the paper that declared idw part of a
mechanism of online echo chambering
has the very same nature in which they
build a model
that creates a shocking impression of a
particular hazard
and when you go back and you scrutinize
what it is that
allowed them to build the model it is in
fact perfectly circular they built into
the model
something that allowed them to pull that
conclusion out and in fact in that case
we had the author
of the article on which their
assumptions were based saying hey you've
misused my work
so it is exactly the same form which
then raises i think a very interesting
question which is
why is why are we facing an epidemic
of this style of science who is certain
well who is served by this who like
i think either who were they working for
or why are they this confused
why are they this bad at actually
understanding how it is that you build a
model that can produce
a result that isn't exactly what you fed
into that model
um i believe the problem is that we are
up against evolution
um what's happening here is very helpful
is it
uh it's it'll it ought to properly
frighten us and uh get us to wake up
because
you know first of all it's mundane but
realize that positions
uh in academia for example are
um scarce and therefore competition to
get them is ferocious and the way one
gets compet
to wins that competition is to publish a
lot of stuff
publish stuff that gets cited by others
etc so in some sense there's a niche
if you can say things that people will
pair it you're going to do well
and in fact we see this if you look at
you know citation rates and how
they affect getting hired it's
spectacular even when you're being
cited because you're being mocked right
in other words the fact that your paper
is cited a lot by people saying this
isn't true
doesn't necessarily count against you so
what i'm getting at here
is i don't know why this is showing up
in
jama right that's shocking and dangerous
as you point out because policy is
almost certain to be founded on this but
what i suspect
is privately as we've seen in many
different places
in the sarsko v2 kovid story
there is a behind-the-scenes consensus
about what
wise public policy is yes and then the
facts are rearranged around it to make
it look like
it is also in your interest as an
individual and so
the idea that um we have a large amount
of transmission from people who never
uh show symptoms of course is justifying
of a lot of the most draconian measures
to prevent the spread of uh covet 19.
and so
in any case what that means is that
people are looking for evidence that we
need to do that those who
have concluded for whatever reason
responsible or not
public-spirited or not those who want to
impose those restrictions are looking
for things that justified and this paper
is liable to be
uh confirming of their worldview correct
or incorrect
and so in any case i guess what i'm
saying is you've got authors
searching for that which the audience
demands and this is
you know as politics is the opposite of
patriotism
uh giving the the audience what it wants
is the opposite of science
science is supposed to tell you what's
true irrespective of what you want to
hear
this isn't science it's circular right
the point is it looks like science it's
dressed up
as science and it is presented in a
sciency place and that is going to be
enough
to drive policy yeah it sure is
and um you know i i desperately want the
cdc to be
awesome and i used to rely
a lot on cdc recommendations uh when you
know when we were doing a lot of
tropical field work and trying to figure
out what vaccinations i needed for where
and um you know the fact is mosquito
mosquitoes don't care about national
borders and so
if you have yellow fever or you know or
zika or malaria one place it doesn't
yeah and you know right next door to one
another um it is one place it's not
another place it's really hard to know
why that
is and the cdc was the cdc's site um
and in fact you used to be able to call
and actually talk with uh
with with people who knew about tropical
diseases
um was really excellent
um i don't know to what degree it was
always also political i assume that
you know every organization of that size
has a has a political arm
but one thing i did not do when i was
pouring through this paper and the other
papers until just now as you were
talking is look and see what the author
affiliations are
of this johansson paper that just came
out and
i am disappointed to find that every
single one of them are at the cdc
none of these are actually university
scientists
um and you know of course the cdc is not
just you know it has a science arm and
it has a policy arm
and um and you know those those things
there should be a firewall between those
things
that policy um should be informed by
science but science should not be
informed by policy
and uh it seems like you may have a
two-way street
going on here well so i would also point
out there's a difference between what
the cdc recommends if you're traveling
to x y or z
place which you know was always good
information but it was often
always too coarse in other words you
might be going to a region of a country
where
you know there isn't malaria and there
would be a recommendation if you're
going to the country
very much so treat yourself for it but
yeah like i'm gonna be at eight thousand
feet like
it's not it's not gonna be a thing but
in this case there's a perverse
incentive and we don't understand it
we don't know whose bidding the cdc is
doing now i would also point out a third
connection here so we've got
this style of work which is on the one
hand totally different than the social
science that goes into you know
scaring people about you know right wing
echo chambers and idw
yeah but the point is okay those two
things look alike because what's going
on is the same
there's a hunt for an audience that is
hungry to hear something
and wants to see it you know scientified
or what i've called
ideal laundering this is the science
version of idea laundering
rather than the critical theory version
but the third thing i would say
needs to be introduced in this
discussion is in fact one of our
um we have like a full-time detractor
whose name i won't mention but
we have a full-time detractor who was um
mocking us
recently it's weird work if you can get
it yeah it's weird work if you can get
it indeed
but anyway he was mocking us for um
being skeptical of models when it comes
to climate change but being
convinced by things like yama peninsula
craters
retreat of glaciers other things that
don't depend on models in order to be
able to interpret where we are
and the point is this is actually the
reason yeah of course
models are complex you can make a model
say almost anything and not for the
right reasons in other words you can get
a model to spit out a behavior that
looks very much like something empirical
but to do so for other reasons if you
add enough parameters into a model you
can get it to look like what you want
yeah as long as you have the right
expression on your face of like
enthusiasm and mild surprise at the
end you can become convinced even
yourself that you didn't just feed your
result
in to the foundational assumptions of
the model right and in fact this is one
of the things i
always ask myself when i see a very good
fit between a model and an empirical
result
is one of two things has to be true
either
it was built into the model so that's
all they could find or
it's accurate so it's not that models
can't be you know
or the model is so narrow in its
parameters that it has very little
predictive power outside of those very
narrow parameters right like you know
the the the more the more general a
model the less accurate it's going to be
and you have to accept that trade-off
when you're assessing whether you know
just
you know if you had an actually good
model that was actually legitimate
and fed assumptions and that were
relevant and you actually
you know slid those that number along
the entire range of zero to 100
for instance and and you know and saw
what it what it spit out then
um you still need to understand that the
model is going to as it gets to be
more and more generally applicable it's
going to have lower and lower accuracy
that is just an inherent
unbeatable trade-off of of models right
but the fact that a model is a match
doesn't tell you anything in and of
itself until you do the kind of work
you've done here so
anyway in a general sense
models are a place that you can bury
any number of bodies if you want to get
x
right as a conclusion a model is a great
way to do it because models are complex
and in fact they did a very poor job of
hiding their bodies here
right they were findable yeah but were
this more complex
more technical it might have been harder
to see the connection yep
and so um in any case what i would say
is we have
misunderstood the p hacking problem p
hacking
being a description of a phenomenon that
was discovered far too late it was
obvious that this was going on
especially in psychology where
effectively the p-value which is a
statistical measure that tells you how
likely a conclusion is to be meaningful
rather than the result of an accidental
sampling error
that this was a place that by obscuring
negative results and only publishing
positive results
you can convince yourself of almost
anything right if you have two things
that don't correlate and you test enough
times eventually you'll get a random
result that says
they do correlate and you can publish
just that one and nobody else is in a
position to even know that the other
tests were done
so my point is why did that happen
because people wanted jobs in psychology
and this was a place where the science
was very hard to track
models are the very same thing so it's
not p hacking there's no p
value there but what there is is the
ability to build in a conclusion in the
assumption layer so we should call it
assumption hacking right will there be a
problem of assumption hacking
in um in models yes where will it be
worst
where the things that are being modeled
are most complex that's one place and
where there is a political prize to be
won
if you reach certain kinds of
conclusions right assumption hacking i
like this
very very much yeah i mean i'm not a fan
but right right
i like the term very very much this is
exactly right yeah i think i think it is
right and so
anyway uh beware the models right it's
not to say you know
models a correct model is
excellent but a correct model and for
many complex systems it's what you're
going to have
well what i would say is a model is not
a hypothesis test a model is a
hypothesis
and when you have a model that says x y
or z is true
that tells you the prediction is we will
also see that in nature
and then you go out and you find it
empirically but the number of people who
think that you can take a model
and test it in the computer and that
this actually saves you the messy work
of going out and sampling
sorry it doesn't right it doesn't i mean
in this case
you know to steal man what they were
trying to do here i
will not attempt to steal man what they
actually did uh but what they were
trying to do
was uh you know having you know we've
been in this for a year at this point
you know and you know not all of us have
been conscious of being in this
this damn pandemic for a year but it's
been a year at this point
and um from the beginning there's been
an active question of
is it just when you're symptomatic or is
it just when you're symptomatic and if
you're going to become symptomatic and
therefore if you're testing positive
or is it you know everyone who has
uh is testing positive regardless of
whether or not they become symptomatic
um who is spreading this thing that's
really going to change how it is that we
need to
you know enforce things like lockdowns
and such
and uh it's been it's been a thorny
problem
to figure out because because
it's a pandemic and these are people and
it's giant numbers of them and there are
all sorts of parameters and that that
paper looking at 1700 people in uh
in brunei was actually remarkable i
didn't you know i didn't even show you
guys the paper but
you know they looked at you know
household transmission versus workplaces
religious transmission they
you know they divided up by age and by
sex and you know all of these things
and uh and still it's really really
tough because if someone
who has been exposed to like you know
three people who tested positive then
becomes positive
you don't know which of those three
people whom they were exposed to they
got it from
right so you just it is this is actually
a very tough thing to know empirically
right so it's a very tough thing to know
empirically therefore this is a place
where
a good model could really serve
to actually uh produce some knowledge
that you could then hopefully try to go
out and test in small numbers
before using it to make policy right and
i would point out if you go back to our
very early live streams we advocated
both at the point that the um aircraft
carrier
uh docked and it's uh it was having a
mini
epidemic and um the patients were
removed rather than
studying them in situ or isolating them
from other
patients we talked about the necessity
that some small population be tested
where these things could be tracked and
i would point out i suggested and i
think
several people pointed out that it was
unlikely to be true it was unlikely to
be possible for
uh security reasons but that an air
force base or
a military base an isolated community
could be used
to study intensively the transmission of
these things and in that context
you could actually figure out who got it
from whom because you could use
sequencing to figure out which mutations
you could do phylogeny
on the various particles floating around
in the population and you could actually
figure out who got it from whom and what
that therefore means about what kinds of
activities are dangerous
and which ones aren't and i think the
final piece to this puzzle
is i don't know how this got politicized
right this covid is it should be
galvanizing not just for
the entire nation it should be
galvanizing for
the world and yet it has been because it
has been dumped into a political
landscape it has been uh wielded as a
weapon
and what we've gotten out of it is
piss-poor policy and
if you had at the beginning said hey
this is this cannot be politicized this
is off limits
and you put smart people together to
figure out how to understand the way
this thing works
what policies work best what you could
have done is an analysis
where you basically had you know you
want to minimize the authoritarian
uh moves under the curve right
so the idea wasn't that's a that's that
move is is
uh destructive of rights the idea is you
want to do minimal destruction so
short-term intensive lockdown for
example outside is safe
go outside uh open the beaches encourage
people to
to go outside so they don't go crazy
outdoors
right whatever it is you could have
gotten very intelligent
highly effective policy and instead what
we got was a compromise between science
and everybody's agenda and the degree to
which they could wield power to make it
happen
and um it's killing people yeah well i
mean it did in its in its defense it did
manage to destroy almost everything
except the virus
yes it's it's uh it's got civilization
back on its heels
and all of that mental health of the
entire world the economic health of
all economies i think yeah absolutely
all right well that was interesting um
yeah i wish so uh i guess
retroactively i want to apologize for
the confusing nature of this i would
you know i would if if i were in a
classroom i would have you know i had
you know powerpoint
slides to show you guys i've been
walking it through somewhat more slowly
but
um the point is
they fed a number that was entirely
justified
unjustified into the assumptions of
their model
and had no business trotting out the
results of that model which said exactly
what
um it had to given what they fed into it
yeah yeah it's uh yes and in some sense
you could uh you could see this it's
almost like
saying um that many on the far
right show no symptoms of being on the
far right and yet we know that
yes no symptoms yes indeed indeed
okay um a couple more things before we
finish up with what you want to finish
up with
um so washington post had
uh a little blurb this week and i found
it this morning and then when i went
back
later this morning it it had been taken
down so i now only find this in like the
telegraph which is payroll in new york
post and
you know i don't really want to be
putting up the new york post on here so
i'm just going to tell you
you already know um uh that
uh basically that the take home here is
that you should walk your husband if you
can't walk your dog
yeah yeah so um there is
i mean i guess here's the new york post
you can go ahead and show it zach so
again
uh wapo had it and they've taken it down
now wait a minute you buried the lead
here that looks like a leaf
um you think she was just walking a
leash
no no i think she had her husband least
or at least that's the implication
yeah i know i mean that that is but
apparently it was they
you know they were both into it
apparently um
so the idea that the idea was it's a
story from uh
quebec uh in canada uh where the only
uh way that you were allowed to go
outside for some period of time
was uh if to walk your dog and of course
this left you out of luck if you had no
dog
and so this woman and her husband
decided that she would walk him
and when approached she claimed that she
was just walking her dog
and they got fined and apparently they
you know yelled at the people finding
them that
they would happily accept the fine and
continue to walk i don't know if they
were going to walk each other if they
were going to swap or if she was always
going to be walking him
um but what goes on between consenting
schnauzers
it's not our business they should keep
it indoors probably
oh yeah yeah yeah well but uh the the
consenting schnauzers part but
um i mean i think this is a a a
brilliant response to an idiotic policy
decision
right yeah i agree right like you you're
allowed to go outside to walk your dog
because we understand you don't want dog
poop in your house
um but and you still apparently you had
to keep uh
keep within a half mile of your home
like you couldn't just go on long walks
what the hell
well yeah this is this is nuts and you
know you and i are getting a horse
uh shouting about how it doesn't there's
no evidence that against transmitted
outside now i
i will keep saying caveat uh let us make
sure
that these new strains that appear to be
much more um
infectious are not simply ones that have
just learned
a trick like that which frankly could be
it's quite possible see no evidence of
it yet but no evidence
but uh i won't be terribly shocked if
that's what's going on so anyway which
which changes the landscape entirely you
know makes this all much more
horrifying frankly yeah um okay
one more thing before um before we go
where you want to go which is
um the another
uh up so don't show us yet zack
um boy i can't remember where i got this
from now
um i think this is the oh this is the
johns hopkins newsletter so i also got a
johns hopkins newsletter that is mostly
doing covet updates
every week and it does counts both
cases and deaths across the world and
then talks about some of what's going on
regionally
and in oceania here you can show now
zack
just the top paragraph australia and new
zealand have both demonstrated this is
from this week
uh the fifth i wanted to see the 15th
but it's not the
yeah i think it was from yesterday the
15th australia and new zealand have both
demonstrated the ability to effectively
contain their respective cova-19
epidemics
considering their success in limiting
transmission both countries are
reportedly delaying their vaccination
campaigns until mid to late february
this extra time will allow health and
regulatory officials to gather more
information on the efficacy and safety
of the various cyrus cov2 vaccines and
vaccine candidates
additionally the delay will provide both
countries an opportunity to better
prepare their distribution plans
um i think this makes the governments of
australia and new zealand
fascists or at least anti-vaxxers
does it not interesting question and to
me
it makes them sound uh quite reasonable
quite reasonable like they have actually
done a good job
on the front end unlike for instance the
united states
of controlling transmission and as a
result
they have a little bit more leeway to
say you know what
let us hold off because these vaccines
are brand new and no matter how safe you
say they are we simply cannot
know that is something that apparently
is what australia and new zealand have
said and
they're allowed to do that so so should
the rest of us be allowed to have those
conversations
and have those questions we should be
allowed to have those conversations of
course we're in a different
as you point out we're in a different
circumstance because the control has
been
uh uh poor to say the least at least um
yep
so which actually brings us to the
second to last thing
which is zach would you put up the
new york times article i sent you on the
coveted vaccine death
so i wanted to point something out here
and i want to be very careful that
people don't over interpret it
um this is
a news report of a death that looks
very much like it was caused
by uh the pfizer
vaccine and i don't say that casually in
this article
uh an expert who was not involved in the
case says it basically it's hard to
avoid
the impression that this was a direct
causal link between
this doctor's death and the vaccine that
he had gotten 16 days earlier
now okay so this is a doctor who has
died
apparently from the vaccine now in and
of itself
i don't think that necessarily means
anything many people are dying from
covid
we should expect there to be a certain
number of
uh strong reactions people's physiology
varies
quite a bit and so every medicine
should be expected to have some extreme
adverse effects on hopefully a tiny tiny
tiny minority of people who are
receiving that medication
that you know a number and anecdote
doesn't say anything
about uh frequency or you know risk
risk rise and in fact zach would you put
up the uh covid vaccine
tracker site that i said yeah
nope there it is
um so we have uh you know numbers that
this death should be uh put in the
context
of so we have um almost
38 million doses have been distributed
in 49 countries
um 2.41 million doses per day
in the united states we've got 13
million shots almost a million
doses are administered per day so these
are very large numbers and one person's
death
you know is certainly shocking and
should give us pause but
it's not in comparison to those numbers
it is not a
reason to panic however you're not
bringing it up for for that reason
right i'm not bringing it up for that
reason but if you'll go back to the
news report and if you could enlarge it
a little bit and scroll down
okay so here it is shortly after
receiving the vaccine dr michael
develops an extremely serious form of a
condition known as a
acute immune thrombocytopenia
which prevented his blood from clotting
effectively myotis is a new disease to
me but my understanding is
that it is effectively the immune system
attacking a component
of the blood clotting the blood clotting
is a very complex phenomenon that
involves a cascade of things platelets
being
the beginning of the cascade where
platelets are broken open spilling out
chemicals that trigger this cascade that
results in clotting so effectively
some uh catastrophic failure of his
clotting ability
uh ensued in the aftermath of his
getting the vaccine and ultimately he
died of it but the reason i raise it is
because
when we were talking about these new
mrna vaccines and the pfizer vaccine is
one of the
newfangled mrna vaccines two or three
episodes ago two or three episodes ago
we were talking about
what we don't know now what we don't
know is anything at all about the
long-term effects
of these vaccines because there hasn't
been a long period of time
since anybody has had them and so
whether or not they turn out to do any
harm
of a long-term nature we have no idea
but is the possibility there yes it's
there not only because these vaccines
haven't been tested
in anyone over a long period of time but
because they are on a new platform and
therefore
possibilities that we could rule out on
the basis that we've never seen x y or z
platform do that before
we can't rule out here because these
things are truly novel or at least have
much higher certainty
that it wouldn't be happening right so
what i do want to point out is that in
talking about what could be downstream
and in my opinion virtually anything
could be downstream
long term we don't know what it means
and the fact is there's enough
novel about these vaccines
that you know and we're talking about a
complex system the human body
we really don't know what's going on but
one possibility is that a vaccine like
this could interact with the immune
system
and cause an autoimmune disorder right
that would be a big frightening problem
now this is one death but that is an
autoimmune disorder and so my point is
just simply
proof of concept can these vaccines
cause an autoimmune reaction
up through the level of being fatal
apparently
i mean you know of course pfizer is
saying it's not connected
well pfizer is doing what it has done
from the beginning which is effectively
using careful scientific language to
suggest
safety in other words yes we cannot
establish anything on the basis of
uh one death even if it's conspicuous
from the connection and so um
what i would say is
we don't know it is also the case that
this very same disorder
can be caused by covit itself
now the cases i believe all of the cases
that have been witnessed and it's not a
huge number
but all of the cases of this disorder
that have been
seen following people contracting covet
have not been fatal
some of them have been serious but in
any case
we are dealing with a complex system the
immune system
is a is built to deal with anything
novel that it runs into and so this is
an obvious possibility and it's
something that we need to track we need
to be thinking about what the long-term
dangers are here and the example of
oceania
deciding to wait a little while and see
what turns up
is wise especially if you've done the
front end part right you've
not allowed this to get politicized and
you've deployed good policy
you can afford to wait yeah good good
for them they had an easier time than a
lot of countries because they're
um the opposite of landlocked right
because they have entirely water borders
um uh of course the u.s is
you know does not have entirely water
borders but uh isn't easy should have
had an easier time
um than say some of the countries in
europe although the sheer size and scope
of the united states makes things more
difficult
yeah well if you'll think back to the
early part of the uh
the epidemic there was talk about
effectively
uh preventing people from crossing our
borders and it was treated
uh as um cynophobic
um yeah well and at this point
american passport has never been worth
so little as it is right now
yeah yeah yeah all right i think we've
got one final thing
yeah we do so um i wanted to relay a
little story that i'm aware
has no actual uh meaning
it has symbolism to it that has no
meaning the story itself has some
meaning to me but i just wanted to
to mention it um so my uh
kids and i have been um riding
in fact all of us have during the summer
ride through
a uh cemetery nearby beautiful cemetery
actually it's
shocking how nice the cemetery is um
so my feeling about it is uh you know if
you have to be dead and i'm not saying
you do but if you have to be dead this
wouldn't be a bad place to do it
it's just it's very beautiful it's it's
giant too i mean it's you know
it's not like we seek out the cemetery
and hang out there it's really really
large and it gives us access to
the river on the other side of portland
right and in fact um you know
people mock portland a lot these days
but because it's portland um there is a
desire to facilitate things like
bicycling and as improbable as it sounds
in a litigious society
the cemetery allows people to
bike through it to get from the
highlands in the southwest
down to the lowlands down to the river
and
in fact it's the only good way to do it
right everything else is dangerous and
trafficky and through the
cemetery is quite beautiful so anyway
it's it's uh whenever we
make that transition we go through it so
you and often one of our boys have been
doing that
um consistently um even as the weather
has gotten terrible
it's probably been since october that
i've gotten on my bike and done it
yeah i forced myself to do it even in
the winter but anyway
so there has been for i don't know i
don't know how long they've been there
but i've been aware for
seven or eight months i'm sure they've
been there a lot longer than that
there's been a pair of bald eagles
that is frequently visible in a tree
on this route and i always check in with
and them and we even named them yes well
i didn't
know i just uh i'm following suit they i
believe they are mitch and fiona
a pair of bald eagles and they raised a
chick uh this summer
um but in any case whenever i go through
i
check to see if i can find them and i
took toby
some time back and uh he actually found
the nest that they were in a totally
different tree a beautiful
giant high high oh quite high up
beautiful uh
eagle airy um you know if you've seen an
eagle nest it must be
eight feet across very large limbs and
all anyway beautiful eagles nest
and so i just check in with it every
time i go through and i was
uh on the day of the impeachment
i was riding through the cemetery and i
was
looking and i couldn't find it
and you know there are a lot of trees so
i figured i'd just forget exactly where
it is
and as i got closer and closer i
realized
it wasn't there and um the tree
had actually collapsed this eagle tree
we had
we had had a massive storm with you know
flooding
and um you know the
84 and the 101 were underwater like
there was a massive storm that we had
experienced so yeah it's not
it didn't just collapse all of a sudden
on a bluebird sky day
no no it didn't uh there was a
tremendous amount of water flowing off
off the hill um i was actually i was uh
on the phone i have a helmet that allows
me to talk and i was talking to our
moderator uh the dark horse moderator as
i was writing
and so she actually heard as i'm
discovering that this
eagle tree is no more yeah zach would
you put up the image
so here is an image of the tree having
collapsed and destroyed
uh a monument there anyway i was very
alarmed
um when i saw this and uh
you know i didn't know if the birds had
gotten out um i found the place where
the nest
would have landed and it was just
absolutely obliterated
and uh anyway it was getting dark the
first time i saw it and i
so they wouldn't have had um eggs or
chicks at this time of year
so this is at least the right moment for
this to fall if it were to not
kill any baby eagles yeah as i was
looking around
i spotted one of the eagles and then i
watched it for a few minutes and the
other eagle showed up so
they survived they're okay um
and uh any in any case i went back the
next day with zach um zach you want to
show the picture
so i wasn't able to get fiona this is
mitch
um i can tell because he's smaller
and that's the way it goes in in bald
eagles
in raptors in general raptors in general
yes actually uh
dick alexander my phd advisor was very
fond of this um
result that sexual competition tends to
make males larger and females smaller
acceptance species that compete in three
dimensions where it goes the other way
yeah so anyway uh
so is it is it true in bats
yes it is it is true yeah oh that's cool
all of them i'm not gonna say that every
1100 species um i'm i'm not going to say
that but yes the ones i'm familiar with
it is true
so anyway here is this bald eagle and
obviously the symbolism that one could
read into this
is uh tremendous
on the other hand um you know it's a
it's a beautiful bird sitting in a
tree at sunset and uh you know it is our
national bird and
and uh anyway quite deserving of that
title so i thought i would point this
out
and um maybe that's it that's that's
gorgeous
he's gorgeous he is gorgeous yeah i hope
i hope he and fiona
um find another appropriate site and
begin building
straight away yes and if they do find
one that i'm able to figure out where it
is i'm going to try to document their
constructing of their their new nest of
which
um you and we have you know some
experience not just when we've actually
been in the field
but uh in our old house actually in
olympia we had
uh stellar's jays build a nest in a
giant rhododendron right outside our
bathroom window
and we watched them raise three chicks
and fledge them and they all survived
and then the next year
robbins took over that same nest and
kind of fixed it up but not really they
were
much they cared much less about the
quality of their housing than the
original jays did
and they raised um i don't remember how
many successful chicks uh i think it was
three
three as well yeah um so uh it's it's
fantastically fun to actually go out
into the world and
observe things um in order to know
what's unusual you have to have we were
talking about this earlier you have to
have a sense of what the baseline is and
so
when you first start spending time in
nature you don't
it doesn't necessarily seem as
interesting to you necessarily because
the the universally charismatic events
are rare you know it's rare that you see
a fight or sex or something
but there is a ton going on all the time
in order to interpret it you need to
know what is normally going on
and whether what you're seeing is
unusual and so you have to
you have the more time you spend outside
with your eyes open the more likely you
are
to start seeing things that are unusual
and fascinating every time you go out
yes and in fact in this case um
surely this is a phenomenon you know
trees fall down at some rate
uh eagles put their nests in trees that
are large enough
to give them a good vantage point which
means they tend to be old trees so this
has to be some sort of a hazard that
the eagles are are having to to navigate
yeah but i would point out actually now
that you mention it
that we have a second experience at a
very different scale
yeah as a family of something very
similar which is
um several years ago three or four
years ago um we were well zach and i
were
a day earlier we were in dunsmere
in california near shasta and you joined
us
a day later but um we had gone down we
took a little walk and we went down by a
river and we discovered
a swallows nest in a snag
so there was a hole in the snag and the
swallows were flying out of it
presumably collecting insects and coming
back and feeding their
chicks and anyway it was pretty nifty to
watch
and you know it was right up your alley
so the next day we brought you
back to see it and we at first couldn't
find the tree
and then it became clear that the reason
we couldn't find the tree was that it
had broken off at exactly the place
where the animals had built their home
inside this hole and they were still
there right but now they're in the top
of it as opposed to the middle
in the open top of this tree so anyway
presumably their building
of you know that whole nesting does
reduce
the um the structural integrity of the
material yes
i mean you know even so some birds might
uh
excavate a little bit i don't know
whether swallows do um
but even if they don't just the simple
fact of the
humidity changes and things if you bring
nesting material
in there it's going to capture uh you
know some humidity it's going to cause
the wood to rot faster
so anyway there's some question hinted
at here
which is you know what is the uh
influence of
nest destruction um you know
on nest building behavior how good are
birds at figuring out
what trees are the best bet oh i've got
maybe
another another segment another time
i've got this beautiful book
on effectively the anatomy of bird nests
of all these different kinds of nests
that birds build under different
situations
um really you know different different
phylogenies of birds and different
different types of nests and i don't
know though how much
has been done on the effective nests on
the underlying substrate
yeah that's a good question and of
course this uh reflects back to
uh to my work my dissertation work on
um tent making bats which is
very destructive of the leaves that they
make
you know tents are these large
understory leaves that the bats cut very
precisely so they collapse in a very
tent-like fashion
um now if in some plants the leaf
you know it the plant doesn't have a lot
of structure
beyond the leaf and in some other plants
you know it's one leaf
where sometimes bats a group of them
will build in one plant and they will
damage a whole bunch of leaves on the
same plant um so anyway there's some
some interaction there uh to be studied
as well in terms of what the effect of
the bats is on the
plants yeah um for sure all right
all right well um so i guess our usual
end of show announcements
we have uh some stuff available
shirts mugs the likes at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
you can join either of our patreons for
access to the discord server which among
other things we take one question a week
from
people voting on them on the discord
server and
you can also get access to the once
monthly
private q a at my patreon and access to
some more intimate yet conversations
that brett has
on his what else um
email darkhorse.moderator gmail.com for
any logistical questions like how do you
ask questions
um for us to answer in the second hour
although we'll say it right now it's
through
for now it's through super chat uh on
on youtube uh we were supposed to have
our next meeting to move forward our
other plan but our power was out for
almost a day in the middle of this week
due to that storm so
we had to delay that and what else
we'll be back for those of you listening
in a week
and for those of you watching if you
have the interest and wherewithal in
about 15 minutes
all right be well everyone we'll see you
shortly
all right